[Music]
so Moynihan said you're entitled to your
own opinion but not your own facts
the thing that wikipedia focuses on is
not truth nor facts it's reliable
verifiable information and what we would
say is that as the world's consensus
changes about what is reliable
verifiable information the information
for us will change too so the example I
like to use because it seems a bit
difficult to dispute at this point in
time is that if helio versus geocentrism
if wikipedia had been around a couple
hundred years ago we probably would have
had an article that says that the Sun
revolves around the earth because that
was what we understood to be true we no
longer understand that to be true thanks
to advances in science and physics but
if tomorrow we were to wake up and learn
that in fact time being relative really
does upend the way that we think about
the world Wikipedia would have to evolve
in order to describe that so we're not
really in the business of truth or facts
we're in the business of what is known
and what has been determined through
consensus scientific consensus or
otherwise and I think that that actually
provides some clarity on how to
understand what information you're
looking at one thing that I think is
really unique about Wikipedia is there's
only one version for the whole public
there's no feed that's curated for you
or for me we all are looking at the same
version of the article and I think
that's actually strength because it
forces editors and it forces
contributors to come to some sort of
common understanding of what the
narrative of a story with the narrative
history what the facts actually are
research has been done by the Harvard
School of Business just earlier this
year that shows that people who enter
into editing Wikipedia with a highly
partisan perspective tend to actually
become more neutral if they stick around
overtime so you might enter in to edit
the article of a politician's page and
if you are
really political or have a perspective
on that politician if you actually learn
how Wikipedia works and continue to edit
what it seems is that Wikipedia articles
are sorry editors start to take on a
more neutral tone and engage in more
neutral ways presenting more facts than
opinion now there's not a lot of places
on the internet that I think make people
less partisan or more oriented around
conversation and discussion and inquiry
and so that in and of itself is sort of
really interesting byproduct of the way
Wikipedia works so every Wikipedia
article is based on sort of these three
core tenets
the first is neutrality Wikipedia
articles have to be neutral in the way
that they present information and what
that means generally is that you don't
see a lot of adjectives in Wikipedia
articles because adjectives are slippery
they can mean different things to
different people they have to be based
on reliable sources and reliable sources
so that's the idea that it's verifiable
you can go back to the source that comes
from and Wikipedians will use different
types of reliable sources depending on
what you're writing about if you're
writing about current events you're
going to use very different sources than
if you're say writing about
eighteenth-century tapestries just
different types of publications cover
these things and the way that
Wikipedians think about reliability is
not about source a is good and source a
B is bad instead it's more around how do
those sources think about and engage in
knowledge creation generation and
critique and so they look at things like
does the source fact check does the
source engage in peer review if the
source is wrong will it issue a
correction and that is sort of the
approach that Wikipedians take to assess
different types of reliable sources for
different areas of knowledge creation
and then the last is no original
research so while new knowledge is being
created every single day until it has
actually gone through a process of
shaping consensus review it doesn't
belong on Wikipedia we are not a place
to break news we are in the sense of new
information we
a place to provide an overview of what
is understood and accepted and the work
has been done other in other forums
subjects also have to be notable in the
sense that they have to be have been
written about by a number of secondary
sources and so notability is not the
same thing as same you might have
somebody who is a very obscure ethno
botanist
but if they have really contributed to
their field and are acknowledged as such
they will be notable even though the
general public may never have heard
about them so those are some of the core
characteristics of what goes into a
Kapadia what doesn't go into Wikipedia
and then how an article is built and
what was fascinating to me was reading
what we call it Wikipedia talk page
every article has a talk page one way of
thinking about it is it's a newsroom for
Wikipedia articles it's where editors
can test it can contest information you
can challenge each other can propose
alternate phrasing for the article can
highlight things that are missing and
can engage in debate what goes on the
cutting room floor and what makes it
into the public article most people
never see the talk pages but they're
there they're public you can click on
them you can read them you can learn
about the discussions and debates that
go into the creation of every article
and it's not just controversial articles
I encourage everyone to look at the talk
page for your hometown it's very
enlightening or entertaining so those
talk pages are where the conversations
happen and you can really start to see
things like the principle of neutrality
at work you can start to see things like
the way information is created and why
it matters to be specific so in this
particular article about the strike of
the US strike on Syria I was looking at
the way they titled it and the
conversation was is it an airstrike well
no because it didn't come from planes it
was see to surface so it's not an
airstrike it's a strike is it a rage no
because there weren't troops on the
ground so we wouldn't call it a raid and
these are the sort of conversation
but Wikipedians have as they hammer out
the specifics of almost every sentence
that goes into an article of course the
more contested an article is the more
controversial subject is the more
attention each individual sentence gets
I don't know if the article is about say
Pokemon are quite as contested but then
again I don't know much about Pokemon so
perhaps they are
[Music]